Match these angles
with their measures.
There should be one
angle in each category.
We have 30 degrees, 60 degrees,
90 degrees, and 180 degrees.
So there's a few that are
very easy to spot out.
This angle right over here,
it makes a complete line.
So this is clearly 180 degrees.
So this one's 180 degrees.
The other one that
might jump out at you
is this one right over here.
This is clearly a right
angle, or a 90-degree angle
right over here.
So this is 90 degrees.
And so we have to think
which of these is 30
and which is 60 degrees?
Well, just by
comparing it that way,
you know that the one
that opens out more
is going to be 60 degrees and
the one that opens out less
is going to be 30 degrees.
And you can see that
this, the opening here,
is half the size of the
opening right over here.
So it makes sense that
this is 30, this is 60,
and it also makes sense
that this angle is 1/3
the measure of this
angle right over here,
that this is 90 degrees.
And then if you
were to double this,
then this part of the angle
would go all the way out,
and you would get
to the 180 degrees.
So let's check our
answer and make
sure we actually
got this one right.
Let's do one more, just for fun.
Which of these angles has
a measure of 60 degrees?
So there's a couple that we
can immediately rule out.
This angle here is clearly
more than 90 degrees.
It's an obtuse angle.
This angle here is
180 degrees, so we're
going to have to pick
between these two.
And we can assume that
these are all at scale.
So if we know that a right angle
would have this line straight
up and down, this looks like
it's 2/3 of the way there.
So I would go with this
one right over there.
Now, you might say, well,
what about this one?
Well, this one looks like it's
about 1/3 of a right angle.
If we were to do
2/3, then 3/3, it
looks like we would
get to a right angle.
So this one looks much
closer to 30 degrees.
So which of these angles
has a measure of 60?
That one right over there.
You could immediately rule
out that one and that one,
and then these take a little
bit closer inspection.